long reot wi the Eds lski tried to dump it down
deep G ronto will give it up and KAG with aister
I think that's a blocker save for PETA if it is
it'll be his first of the game Chandler Stevenson
is in with a r shot hman gets it back centering
pass denied here's eel in the corner over to meet
him was Jan there's a long R shot and there's
a save by goria that should have just been Let
Go by both Cormier will bump it for Stevenson
to eel on the near side swept off Cormier shot
save gorgia batted over to the near side picked
up by eel you see the numbers right there Vegas
in the middle of the pack on the power play
quick shot save depending on the day here's
petrangelo works his way in the big defens with
the wrist shot there's a blocker save by goria
barbashev G it off for Io who's switched sides
got the way there out of ax is Jack Johnson the
one for one in the kill IO up top and a onetime
Martinez glove save goria he's going to hold on
nice job by McKinnon there playing on the
defensive side of the puck after drean got
stripped challenge White Cloud that puck up the
board as Gerard is there a little sidestep move
sends it down deep it's gloved by P he'll hold
on it's first time Bo his call if he was sent
down to the miners for four games best game I've
ever seen him play two nights AG against Bruins
back to tapes it comes long re shot save
rebound no McKennon was there and W just
poked it away at the last second nobody got the
message synchronize your watches nice little tip
pass byus back down low down s p down rebound
this was precision up the middle Ross Colton
there's the give there's the go tries to stop
it backand peta's pad is actually off the ice
here Ross colon drives to slide it under but
he gets in too tight and can't really make
him play it almost just stuffs it into the pad
Sam molinski three to foot as he works his way
ahead Jones takes it down the wing sends it on
that hit the side of the king calano will dump
in Chase triangulo turn it up not out Jones puns
biny down deep kick save K RTO over skates the
rebound oh K RTO was already thinking P dir but
he didn't get it on his back hand that puck was
spinning couldn't crou for a good chance you've
got to love that shot by malitzky kept it right
on the ice knew he wasn't going to score but a
rebound opportunity was there ab's not out of
it yet here's one in the far Corner msk's got a
brain on him Martinez with a hesitation now he's
shot point right to the side of the cre gorgia
getting himself wide he'll scoop it in Dallas
for smoking Minnesota tonight penalty coming
up on TES back the other other way D shoots
It Wide of the Nets eel's been all over the ice
in the power play Walk cut off nowhere to go Mel
steers it off to him pu is loose into the crease
smothered by Dior back in by the golden kns kimy
R has stick on that one Freddy olon brings it in
olon now a two on one K Ron save by P we bound
it's underneath him wasn't a clean pass across
but K Ron watch he grabs it on the backend wins
that puck battle no points in his last 13 for K
ronto just itching looking for anything and need
a little puck luck on his side but this play by
olon right here just to keeps skating the Vegas
player Dives that allows the opportunity for the
two-on-one and Yuri Peta once again just gets the
big body down covers the rebound no chance for
the ABS we can see get up here that would have
been a partial breakway by Logan o Conor but puck
just couldn't get to him fast enough before it
got picked off WS at the middle back in flip
theor again right thereor could not get a pad
on Stevenson Rams It Off White Cloud sends
it to the front of that goria closes the
pass HS one the draw mcau steers it off for
Dr bran in the Trap as well continue going
through power B toin it's a power play goal a
perfect little feed from the anent right into
the low slot it's a thingy Beauty watch
nio Rance sof pass right over the tape
of mcnf right on valan stick look at that
pass Val just sitting there nobody on him
drops down out of the sky a perfect sof pass
look at the height drop down perfect Chu got
up for 12 Power Play Goals on the year for
batusin and the got one up the I think you
should just has with the draw on the steers it
off for Dr ran in the Trap is continue going
th out of the box is Boo set ahead
McKinnon DS it for him RS it in his
in he's got mckinon with him shoots rebound
over SK ABS on top of the goal night's one-
nothing Meo r in it even though it was
five on five it looked like the ABS were
on a power play there for a second cter
stops pop shot off the post rebound sa by
goria one in Colorado on the power play
Froman andan as we said earlier lots of
different line combinations in this game you
called the mosy see there went for a quick R
shot just barely missed the top right corner
straight up Toppers kale truway cross one time
oh my gosh the sa reat score B and his second
power play goal of the game as he cleans up
right on the doorstep and the ABS have take it
a two nothing lead and 13 in front of the that
just can't be stopped McKinnon couldn't believe
he missed that pu but the good news is the kin
is going to get the second assist that's going
to keep the keep the home scoring streak alive
what a backhand pass by Mo ranin there's the
wide open net doesn't get better than that Mo
stays with it slick play in Bal tokin well that's
weird like deja even Tyson Barry oland's records
we never thought were going to be touched and
these guys are just Galloping by here's mckin
down deep gives it off shot sa Peta smart about
everything here hech MOA five nothing needs a
bit of a tenous leading today's NHL fire to
LZ he'll race in oh shoots and is save by
Peta ging off Maro
he'll dance on the far side Michael looking
to Dish off Stone was for a back door play
not available now in front save goria not
once but twice on the stick of F oliv and
and out it goes what a couple of Saves by
gor got watched this Sav by gorv Mark stone
is wide open that goes off the toe and then he
has presence of mind to keep his Pad there and
not let it slide back but Stones their top scorer
second on their team in scoring right now not one
the corner Colton will crash but there's colar
thre it up Jones again keeps it alive L shoots
score I think Ros colon may have gotten a
piece of it who was it the ABS have a three
nothing lead Logan o Conor is the first one to
the bench it might be him I think he went off
of P so this will be a Logan o Conor goal and
the ABS are on top by three for LL his seventh
of the season and he stays hot creeping up to
his career high in nine and that's exactly what
happened that's why he put the puck on that
at all times and make that four game point
streak a five game point streak for Logan o'
Conor yeah nice play by Sam Gerard just sits
back waits for Maro to come to him and soon as
he goes for the tow drag just puts a stick out
there and tips it away here's egg right on the
tape watch out Dennis go save by goria again 412
to go in Period three the MS at full command 3
nothing back to the ab Zone played by goria off
his body one to go double do it the Colorado
Avalanche offer up a little payback on Vegas